[Applause]
do you ever wonder where protesters come
from after the Prime Minister prorogued
Parliament they were everywhere from
London to Manchester how did they find
each other and how'd you get them to
turnout
even in the rain the answer can be found
here at the home of Mike Goldsworthy
founder of popular remain campaign
scientists for EU for the last seven
months he's been secretly working with
local remain activists to help them
build support on Facebook we've worked
with over a hundred local pages now and
spent over a hundred thousand pounds in
tools in one-on-one help and also in
advertising directly for those pages we
have quadrupled the amount of people
following local pro you pages with
dozens and dozens of pages where they
were small ineffectual pages before
they've really come alive and built a
community and that is fuelled the
on-the-ground community as well
politics on Facebook is hardly new but
what I've just seen marks a definite
shift on the remain side people are
moving from amateur to professional and
whether you like it or not that is how
modern political campaigns are won and
lost these are the local remains
Facebook pages Mike's working on one
hundred and sixteen of them he says
they're now beating their leave
equivalents in almost every area of the
country although social media experts
are skeptical the results are impressive
but the problem is it doesn't really
give a full spectrum of people's beliefs
a lot of people on the leave side won't
necessarily engage in this sort of
content on social media they're much
more like the shy Tory type of people so
they sort of are passive on social media
they see things they don't really
comment they don't really like rose on
the remain side it's a lot more vocal
still the network's having an impact as
this protest in Cheltenham shows it was
arranged on Niki Robson's Facebook page
which six months ago had just 130
followers now
now Nicky can call on 4000 followers to
protest her local MP you know come with
us tomorrow lunchtime and let's have a
conversation with him about what his
views are on what's taking place so
within 24 hours we arrived at his office
and there were around 300 individuals
from from his constituency so now you
know a lot of protesters come from
Facebook as MPs debate this week
remember the fight online could be just
as crucial role and mantle Sky News